[Musique]
c'est quoi cette sortie scolaire qui
claque le sol là
[Musique]
va disparaître personne ne fait rien oui
tu m'as parlé d'une balade dans la
montagne toi tu ne descends dans un trou
de 15 mètres
j'avais l'air ridicule face aux parents
moi je suis à fond vous êtes chez vous
mais pas des gants
[Musique]
tu pourrais pas leur faire faire un
simple exposé sur le réchauffement
climatique avec un petit diapo comme
tout le monde tu as vu le monde qu'on
est en train de leur laisser là je veux
que vous soyez une équipe
vous arrêtez de jouer avec mes enfants
c'est donner à fond et on pourra même
pas poser une vache vous voulez vous
battre pour se glacier oui ou non
tout ça c'est fini tu voulais qu'il
bombe le torse non
regardez bien parce que tu les changes
un prix
sinon on est capable de faire bouger
toute une balle de quoi vous vous seriez
capable
[Musique]